hey guys it's Dennis the founder take
care and I'm David Griffin your resident
comic book in video game guru and this
is our review of almost-human episode
three are you receiving
so I read online that this episode
actually was shot and was supposed to be
I think the fifth or sixth episode like
there isn't really anything that ties it
to anything so it's kind of a standalone
where you could have placed it almost
anywhere right it felt a little
disjointed it was fine but it was like
last week's episode was episodic right
and we talked about that but I was fine
with it because it was fun and it was
kind of engaging this was it didn't
really do much I don't know it was just
I did the plot I wasn't as into I still
liked the leads of course but this one
wasn't as strong as the first two
episodes though this is the weakest of
the three so far yeah I mean I kind of
have mixed feelings about this one
because there are things about it that I
liked more than last week's episode but
then also there's other things I didn't
like
you know last week's episode I didn't
really care for the episodic story
button they did tie in some cool stuff
about like you know what is death yeah
especially in AI world and also they
tied in a John's old partners for me
right and I thought that stuff was great
this one didn't have any of that but it
did have some good banter I thought
between Dorian and John nothing I agree
I think that's the strongest point of
the series so far is the is John and
Dora I think when they're together
that's always interesting whether he's
telling the story about falling through
the ice or fixing Dorian's you know
getting shot with some gum and I mean
those those parts of the best the whole
thing with this Holy reclamation group
or whatever they weren't acting - you
know rob a bank or whatever they were
stealing the hi so I just didn't get me
I know it's a standard heist hostage
yeah story and then you see a lot so
nothing special of that but I did like
seeing some of the technology they were
showing some of the og off in terms of
like hey this is like a face fix or
change or whatever and this is a you
know what Dorian was able to
tapping to the the 911 imitated John's
voice no so I thought those moments were
kind of cool but yeah you in the whole
episode storyline wasn't that great yeah
I just like it did no I didn't know that
that was supposed to be episode five
yeah how'd it make sense maybe when the
blu-ray comes whatever just to see it in
order if it does the proper order would
be interesting to see if it would fit
better more context maybe because I just
felt like this episode it did seem very
standalone it's just you know that I
mean we haven't heard about the in
syndicate group since the first one his
ex-girlfriend we haven't had any mention
of her so I hope they don't push it off
too long I hope to certain because this
isn't like a full 20 episode season I
don't think so I hope they started
getting to that story sooner than later
so yeah I mean maybe the the real 30
episode has that stuff in yeah they're
holding off on it maybe they want to
show this one because they felt it was
more action-packed yeah cuz this one
definitely had a lot more action sure in
it than previous stuff the hostage story
is fine every now and then yeah but just
so far we don't know or care right other
than maybe them two main characters was
all I care right yeah exactly I don't
mean I just wanted to see a little bit
more with the overall story I want to
meet more of the cast I want them to be
developed a little bit more but it's all
like I said when John and Dorine are in
a scene it's always enjoyable but I want
them also to interact more with the cops
packet yeah yeah I coordinators I mean
you know there was a funny scene of John
pretending not to hear Maldonado
but they don't really interact with like
Valerie Mika Kelly's character she's
always the voice on the receive and
there's like that guy like that hates
them but he really wasn't in this
episode no no I just adore Ian's
relationship with other the other
Androids be kinda nice to see some of
that yeah I hope I'm sure we'll get it
it's just you know it's the third
episode so I get it takes time with this
one I think of the three was my least
favorite I liked the first one I really
liked the second episode with his xbox
but this one I thought I don't know it
was fine it's just I thought very
average for what the show can do but the
two leads are great yeah I hopefully
they don't drag this out yeah we start
getting into some better longer more
importance though
right yeah this huge feature istic world
I want to see more because I really you
know not really interested in what
happened like I don't know what it has
any consequence to the overall in the
long run I mean unless that girl that he
saved helps him in some way in the
future I don't know how that's another
thing so I think she was a plot device
for justice right so alright guys so
that's what we thought the episode are
you still watching almost human or you
liking you enjoying it uh do you want
them to continue with this episodic
formula or do you want them to go into
bigger storylines you're gonna post your
comments below on the website think
CARICOM or on our youtube channel think
AeroPro make sure you subscribe that you
can also come shadow dennis and i on
twitter share your feelings you know
talk to us about what's you're thinking
about almost-humans so far what
direction I could see you go in we're at
think here oh I'm at Griffin de and we
also have a Facebook page that's
facebook.com slash think hero fans make
sure you like that page and you can
share and tweet out oh yeah our videos
that help out a lot
[Music]
[Applause]
you
[Music]